In this next section, we're going
to create the main level sequence for our exercise.
To do that, we are going to add the level sequence
either one of two options.
We can do it within our content browser,
or we can do it from our menu.
Let's jump over to the project real fast,
and I'll show you where both those options exist.
So we can add a sequence from the main toolbar
and do add level sequence.
Or if you prefer to create your sequence
in a specific folder, we can open up our content browser.
And in this case, I'm going to go to our courses, sequence
105.
And I've got this map here, this folder, sequence example.
You can do that too by right clicking and adding a folder.
Name it whatever you'd like.
And inside of there, we can right click cinematics
and add a level sequence.
So we'll go ahead and do that.
And we'll just call this SCQ for sequence underscore 105.
And then I'll just type in example.
Now before we dive into creating the camera and character
animations in our sequence, let's
cover the basics of working with level sequences
and how and where they should be placed.
Sequences are independent actors
that often reference content from within our levels,
but they can function independently of a level.
It's a common practice to add the sequence actor to a level,
since the sequence often references level actors.
As a best practice recommendation,
you can either, one, name the sequence after the level,
or place it directly in it.
Either option provides clarity on which level
the sequence is associated with, but for our exercise,
we'll add the sequence actor into the level.
So let's jump back to the project real fast,
and I'll show you how to do that.
So once our sequence is created, all we need to do
is just drag that actor into the world.
I'll switch on game mode, and you can see now
we have that sequence actor available,
so we know that it's going to be referencing
the content within our level.